[Musique]
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2022 a fait apparaître très de
manière très nette un certain nombre
d'insuffisances pour ne pas dire le
problème assez majeur le premier
problème c'est le fonds chaleur le fonds
chaleur qui normalement est destinée à
soutenir les énergies renouvelables et
nous avons d'ailleurs que les énergies
renouvelables sont indispensables nous
avons un objectif qui est de 23% de
production d'énergie renouvelable or en
2020 nous sommes qu'à dix neuf pour ça
c'est à dire que donc nous sommes encore
loin or les crédits sont insuffisants
nous avons donc proposé de les augmenter
de façon importante
et puis parallèlement
la pollution
je rappelle quand même qu'il ya 48 mille
morts par an dus à la pollution de l'air
en france c'est quand même
aux problèmes qu'il faut donc regarder
de près alors la pollution de l'air et
de vérifier par 650 stations et 19
associations de surveillance de la
qualité de l'air à notre pays
ces associations membres de moyenne et
puis il ya le haut conseil pour le
climat que le président de la république
a créé au rien 6 posts tu as plein
grande-bretagne à 24 emplois et donc
demandolx augmentation de ses emplois et
donc nous voulons renforcer saut au
conseil pour le climat qui est une pièce
indispensable à l'évolution du
développement durable et de son contrôle
[Musique]